[Music]
and needle-dick news needle dick needle
dick needle dick meat all dead like
straw for sure oh yeah you can't even
see it's a coffee strong submitted by
asian parenting one day all someone's
gonna get slapped a boy says the insert
is sewing needle in his urethra to keep
himself awake for homework Oh what is
this in a what there's one that hurts to
hear the headline yeah hurts yeah he
shoved a sewing needle right up his
great abandon what coffee like what I've
never thought about shoving anything up
any caddy for one and then much less the
[ __ ] pee hole
Nazis used to do that really yeah they
put shards of glass and like in a big
surf on teeth row no torture okay well
yeah that's a second I wonder why you
went straight to the dick because like
the first step is putting a thumbtack
under your toll or some [ __ ] right Oh
we'll do that [ __ ] when they want to
pass a lie-detector or whatever oh
really yeah bonus even I'm driving I
roll the windows down and get the cold
air on this [ __ ] shove a needle up my
dick wait what country what Asian
countries ah yes yes China China I'm
gonna say Japan oh I'm gonna say New
England is it China yep so it's China so
basically what happened was this boy
he's from Shanxi which is a new moral
character of China he was apparently so
desperate to stay awake doing his
homework that he took one of his
grandma's long acupuncture needles oh
just shove it right down his urethra
which is the sensitive tube I've heard
which urine has pushed out of the body
yes so it's not exactly clear how that
helped him stay awake but that's what he
told his mom was screaming and so what
happened he gets into the hospital yes
he went to the huh what if he was like
just trying to jack off and experiment
with his dick and then he was like oh I
was just trying to stay away from a
homework
I actually 50% of me believes that story
that's what I can that's possible huh oh
this is guys in like your middle 1200
definitely definitely uh yeah definitely
looking around at your Dave trying to
[ __ ] me you're trying to [ __ ] with her
god damn it dude I feel like uh I know I
tried [ __ ] a magazine the 12th what
did you do roll up the magazine yeah
yeah I was already looking at the girl
the American Pie so I was like I'll just
roll it up and he just tried this
doesn't feel good you just try different
things
did you try to [ __ ] where the girl was
yeah yeah paper that's the right idea
magazine no I just didn't feel just too
hard and you know wonder at that age
your dicks really sensitive yeah soon it
was like one of the edges of the
magazine touches it oh [ __ ]
I'm surprised you didn't pay per
contraction I just said people think the
most mild version of this a kid you've
no idea so so the mom of this
twelve-year-old first noticed something
was wrong when he refused to do his
regular exercise session after lunch and
she made him go outside
regular exercise it was still I know he
was stuck here the needles no no no no
exercise session join her for a walk to
complement to compensate for the miss
workout and she noticed him walking much
slower than you know a regimen yeah
right and the mom thought maybe he's
throwing a tantrum maybe he's just
pissed off at her so she beat him and in
fact they didn't work so she's like no
what's really going on he's like I'm
gonna put a needle in your urethra
oh there's one back whatever however she
got out of him she got him to confess
that he put a metal needle up his
urethra to keep himself awake during
homework is what he said and now it's
worldwide news right that's crazy they
don't have the boys name and tell no one
mom please and it's like it becomes
worldwide news man yeah how did having
the mom break this to the world like my
son hey news news news reporter and uh
it's like I'm going to be home I think
you know like the doctor probably leaked
the information so yeah so when after
the son told her that she took him to
the hospital the whole Hospital start
talking
but how does this work in China I mean
they probably don't have a baby
confident right you probably don't have
like the the patient-doctor confidence
you [ __ ] up you logged up so the
surgeon there at the hospital found the
needle so far up the boys you're still
in close to his bladder oh yeah who's 10
centimeter needle Christ it's like three
or four inches the whole size of his
dick yeah and basically that a lot of
people don't buy the boys story oh yeah
because they think it's child abuse he
said oh they think that he was trying to
[ __ ] around and yeah well he was jacking
off from your pain threshold has to be
so [ __ ] high right if you go if you
get chlamydia right isn't that how they
treat it they have to yeah they say
something in that it the medication goes
through the urethra so we Sheriff anyone
out there has gotten chlamydia and has
gotten something in their urethra please
verify the pain I didn't have chlamydia
but I did have kidney stones and they
had to shove a camera all the way up my
or you don't know that first or you told
yeah yeah but they shove the camera up
there and then they blasted my kidney
stone oh yeah and then they left a stent
in there to collect all the particulate
so I had basically for a week I had like
tubes sticking out of my dick yeah they
don't hurt to pay oh it's not stood and
even now it's been you know what's eight
months since then I can still when I
have to go to the bathroom and I'm
holding it I could still feel where the
stent was like on the side of my body
like there's so much fun I took a muscle
relaxer in school in time and uh
for fun no just II well you know what I
was trying to like I thought it was
gonna help me focus and uh about an hour
later I was on the ground and I wasn't
gonna need to get something to eat
because my back just kept hurting and
I went to get food I couldn't hold it
down so then I found myself like just
kind of walking in a circle on my side
and I went to the hospital cuz I was
like I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on they told me I had kidney stones they
were trying to like break down through
the urethra yeah my college roommate had
kid was it painful like a [ __ ]
on the muscle relaxers been there before
did you pass him yeah I passed him and
he didn't have to get surgery no I
didn't hurt or anything
popped out of your [ __ ] dick I was so
scared to pee they gave me like some
numbing [ __ ] I don't want to pee I don't
want to pee cuz I don't want to I'm just
imagining like [ __ ] rats coming out
my dick
yeah wouldn't the pain when the pain
happened could you even move and [ __ ] no
yeah it was hard for me to move but I
peed it out and like I guess they were
just like crumbs or dirt or something I
don't know but I didn't feel anything I
pictured a marble oh yeah shooting on it
and you hear that noise in the toilet
but it's so small it they're like
they're so small and you like they get
they came to get really big but that's
when they got a blasphemer right yeah
yeah my college roommate had it and it
was after his night of drinking and so
we were like yeah you're hungover and
he's like like a dog he's just wrong oh
I'm like I was like oh he must be
throwing up like - am i you write down
when you go to hospital and then he was
like you can stand they said its
equivalent to like um like furniture
yeah exactly
oh my god so the takeaway lesson here is
tonight get this and why do we prove
stay hydrated water it's hereditary it's
hereditary
[Laughter]
the doc told me straight up he's also
had kidney stones and he said it's
hereditary
but Nicky said only one of the four
doctors said that the other three were
like it got a yes the other thing I've
never had it before and they didn't say
it's a hydrogen only one of them said
that what it is is like they the this
stuff in your kidneys becomes calcified
which makes it turn into that I don't
know they I just keep them clean flush
my kidneys out I'll drink water
they cuz I never feel it how long has it
been since you had that I mean ten years
so that's what happened to me it was own
10th year that I got it again oh you had
it 10 years ago
mm-hmm you're supposed to get it every
10 years no no no it's just but do they
blast it the first you know I passed him
pass the first time yeah
second time is when I had to get it
surgically removed well guys let's start
the countdown there's gotta be a way you
could flush it out is real quick what's
your take water water doesn't do [ __ ]
I'm telling you what I've done the same
thing for 10 years bro I'm a guy of
routine treat monsters yeah [ __ ] yeah I
have ever since my improv day this one
person had monsters so doing that [ __ ]
for 10 years I'm telling you bro it just
it's just hereditary does it right into
our family no you go no though it could
be a grandpa had it your grandma had my
grandpa had a big time and my mom had
them when she was giving birth they all
Jake monster huh I'm sure it helps yeah
I think this kid though back to the guy
that's like the [ __ ] needle in his
dick I think he was masturbating is I've
been thinking about it if you're did you
want it off oh no they're not thinking
about what he was doing I'm like if your
dick is soft I mean how do you like I
mean your dick went out to be correct
you know for it to have a straight shot
down the center you know what if he was
like kind of like slowly looping it in
like that do you think he disinfected
the needle everything along the way do
you think he was heating it up
disinfecting anything I'm gonna do this
right I'll call swap yeah I just think
he should have been honest and told his
mom he's like you know what mom I'm a
pain [ __ ] mm see ya
you know what mom I'm trying to grow my
dick right now I'm trying to be a man
he's trying to keep your heart yeah oh
that's pretty tight make it bigger I
mean who knows a five year olds mine is
[ __ ] crazy
darkest darkest depths of the human
psyche your old boy yeah I can pierce my
dick how'd you get pierced at all no I
was asking God you're like 13
he's a gangster though he's like oh my
dears my dick cuz I'm a [ __ ] girls
good at what kind of porn you watching
man dude damn kid dude he's enough for
some pain [ __ ] I think he must you have
to be cuz you start with like you know
I'm gonna take you know paper clips and
clothes pins and just like pinch myself
and be a dumb kid you're like no I'm
gonna take it because there is that
whole thing where people get horny off
of pain and [ __ ] like step on the bombs
ballbusting yeah dude he's like when my
mom yells at me I get hard what's next
take it to the next level that's how we
got here
Wow yeah well he must have put other
things in there and was okay Legos
whatever he's [ __ ] 12
have you seen that shock video no things
like kids in the sandbox I think oh god
Tina which one wait wait is this one I'm
not sad can I say it
yep okay so basically it's this guy
there's a girl and she has a dildo and
it looks like a normal-looking dildo and
she's shoving it into his penis through
the urethra yeah and he's loving it he's
shoving a dildo up his urethra yeah the
girl kids in the sandbox but he's don't
look it up and obviously [ __ ] it's gotta
be fake I can't remember what time you
dance me how can you fit a dildo through
it I think it has to because it would
cost too much like structural dip how
big is this hole I'm gonna call my dad
and ask her what her dad knows he's got
all the hot [ __ ] no I just I'm like what
is the obvious what's the maximum object
size your dad's like two girls one cop
that's just he's like what he'll be
he'll definitely if I call him in 3
months people oh my god
I have a question if I were to stick
first I don't even know if you would
know what a dildo what Collin put on
speaker huh that'd be tight
is that the doctor let's see it both of
his parents doctors you must know what a
dildo is if you if you say a male he's
going to be utterly confused perfect and
you want to hear I'm a doctor first
lighten Jiki news pause yeah I think I
should call my mom but she might waiting
to ask a doctor a question on the office
I'm gonna call my mom because the
internet knows my mom better than my
because my dad will just call me an ass
on hang on what are her Qaddafi's a
radiologist okay oh yeah yeah don't know
more than I would they're both doctors
great mom
hey mom uh so um I'm live right now on a
on a youtube show and I have to ask you
a medical question what no I got to ask
you a medical question because this
Wheatley talk sure I'm gonna ask you the
question it's just some stupid news
article about some stupid kid doing
stupid [ __ ] but you got to just answer
medically okay don't yell at me now I'm
gonna tell you right now so this kid in
China took a acupuncture needle is dad
with you by the way go get him go get
him go get like run out run what like
your life depends on it okay anyways
this kid took an acupuncture needle and
shoved it in his urethra so our question
is what is the biggest thing that you
can put in your urethra before basically
splitting your penis in half all right
but how big is the two what's the
diameter of the tube ask about the dildo
can you ask my dad that question have
dad called me back immediately Talman
it's emergency asked him if he could
Fedotov us on adult I'm gonna go back to
med school
no let me ask dad dad dad no seriously I
got a serious question you're gonna
think it's stupid it's mental it's a
medical question you're you're live
right now on TV on internet TV so
there's a kid in China he stuck an
acupuncture needle in his urethra we
want to know what's the biggest object
you could stick in your urethra with
before breaking your dick in half no
like you know what I mean like 170 so
like if I wanted to take an object that
was like the size of a banana to two
inches he's two inches so you're saying
one centimeter is the max I can't get
bigger than that wait dad you know do
you know what a dildo is doctor do you
know what a dildo do you know what that
is that's exactly what I thought there
you go people thank you
[Music]